here you are as a person
and your brain is divided in half and
this idea Pops in here into your
conscious mind
now if you have a strong enough plan or
commitment total commitment no matter
what it is going to happen if you have
enough content Ki enough strong enough
internal feeling attached to a plan and
that internal feeling will cause it to
drop into your unconscious mind then
you'll manifest it that's the way the
mind works if you think and Grow Rich
read as a man thinkers read any book
that will teach you the principles that
create wealth and that's what they'll
teach you that's the fundamental of it
all so the key here is to create a
strong enough internal feeling that it
drops into your unconscious and one way
to do that is create a plan right
another one is to create the kind of
commitment that it doesn't matter
whatever it takes to find a way but see
that has to be a consistent emotion